ورثت ثروه كبيره عن والدها الملياردير
الالمانيه هاربتون ولكنها رفضت ان تكون
مجرده وريثه مال فاجتهدت وحصدت الشهاده
الاكاديميه في الاعمال كما نجحت في تعزيز
اعمالها التجاريه وتوسعتها لتجمع ثروه
تقدر ب 24 مليارا و500 مليون دولار فما
قصه سوزان ثلاثه اغنى سيده في العالم في
مدينه بادهمبرج عام
1962 ولدت سوزان حنه وهي ابنه هاربتون من
زوجته الثالثه ومساعدته جوانا برون وهو
احد اهم الاسماء في صناعه الاعمال
بالمانيا ووليد ثروه كبيره فعندما توفي
والده عام
1954 ترك له تكتل شركات كوانز الذي يضم
نحو 200 شركه بمجالات البطاريات والمعادن
والنسيج والكيماويات وعاشره في المئه من
شركه قام الاربانز ونحو 30% من بي ام
دبليو وهي الثروه التي انقسمت بينه وبين
شقيقه هارالد كانت شركه بي ام دبليو
متعثره انذاك فاقترحت اداره بيع المجموعه
عام
1959 لكنك وانت زاد حصته ل 50% ومولى
سياره بي ام دبليو 700 ليعيد الشريكه
للمسار الصحيح توفي هاربت عام
1982 وتم تقسيم الثروه بين ابناءه فحصلت
سوزان على الماجستير باداره الاعمال كانت
سوزا قد تدربت في عدد من البنوك
والاستشارات الاداريه قبل ان تتدرب في
شركه بي ام دبليو فاصبحت مستعده لمرحله
جديده كسيده اعمال وعيده بالمانيا عندما
حصلت سوزا على 25% من شركه النوركس
الرائده في صناعه الرياح جعلتها واحده من
الشركات الرائده في اوروبا كما رفعت
ستواليدها الموروثه عن جدها بشركه التنا
المتخصصه في تصنيع المواد الكيميائيه الى
50 وواحد من 10% واسهمت في جعلها شريكه
كيميائيه متخصصه على مستوى عالميه ثم
استحوذت من خلال شركاتها الاستثماريه
سكيون على بقيه اسهم وفي عام 2010 اصبحت
المالك الوحيده لها والتي تبلغ مبيعاتها
السنويه اكثر من مليارين و500 مليون دولار
وفيما يتعلق بشركه بي ام دبليو موتورز ورث
سوزان 12.5% من اسهم الشركه وفي عام
1997 انضمت لشقيقه ستيفن كوانز بمجلس
الاداره عزت سوزا اعمالها بشكل كبير
لتمتلك حصصا في انجلتراس المتخصصه في
الهويه الرقميه ومجموعه اس جي ال المنتجه
للكربون والجرافات وشركه التكنولوجيا
الحيويه الهولنديه باكس وشركه افيست
لاعاده تدوير الزيوت وتشارك ايضا في سلسله
من المشروعات التجاريه الاخرى تبلغ ثروه
سوزان كلاسن اليوم 24 مليارا و500 مليون
دولار وهي حاليا اغنى امراه في المانيا
وتحتل المرتبه الثامنه في قائمه اغنى نساء
العالم
[موسيقى]